[Musique]
encore très marginal il ya quelques
années à peine les crypto monnaies sont
maintenant sorti de l'ombre appelez vite
quand il était au royaume des dieux ou
bnb l'équipe de monnaie se comptent par
milliers et leurs adeptes se comptent
par millions des sommes colossales
d'argent sont en jeu mais il y a un an
vers à la médaille en 2022 à l'échelle
mondiale fraude rime de plus en plus
avec crypto monnaie au canada seulement
entre 2017 et 2020 le nombre de fraudes
associés aux cryptes aux monnaies a
augmenté de plus de 400% or il s'agit de
la pointe d'un iceberg des autorités
estiment ne recevoir des signalements
que pour seulement 5 % des fraudes
perpétrées au pays ailleurs dans le
monde un cas très récent a retenu notre
attention pas plus tard que cette
semaine l'équivalent de 625 millions de
dollars en kryte aux monnaies ont été
dérobés par de cyberpirates dans une
chaîne de blocs pourtant censés protéger
des avoirs d'amateurs d'un populaire jeu
vidéo
un exemple parmi tant d'autres qui nous
montre à quel point s'aventurer dans cet
univers comprend son lot de risques
malgré les profits mirobolants qu'on
nous fait miroiter
625 millions $ énorme ça c'est un seul
cas un seul incident de vol de crypto
monnaie et on dit depuis le début de
l'année 2022 ces vols l'un se chiffre à
plus d'un milliard de dollars c'est
hallucinant pour qu'on se comprenne bien
que tout le monde nous comprenne sa part
nous seul etc et aux monnaies donc c'est
parti suite au crash financier de 2008
dont les banques ont fait planter le
système financier en inventant des
formes de plus en plus exotiques
d'investissement énormément ébranlé la
confiance envers le système finances il
pour toutes sortes de très bonnes
raisons et puis
là dedans émerge un personnage qui
arbore les pseudonymes satoshi nakamoto
on sait pas c'est qui c'est un
pseudonyme sur internet son identité
jamais été dévoilé et cette personne le
propose une nouvelle monnaie
électronique qui va pouvoir contourner
le système bancaire pour des raisons
idéologiques
satoshi nakamoto évoluent dans des
formes édition des communautés en ligne
qui ont des tendances anarcho
capitaliste en narco libertarienne
beaucoup préoccuper page toute forme de
pouvoir étatique qu'il juge comme étant
complètement illégitime il cherche à
contourner tout pouvoir politique en
utilisant l'internet et dans ses
programmes le circule énormément de
conspiration à propos du système
financier à propos en particulier des
banques centrales dans sa vision du
projet d'être quand on voit des et cours
de ces conspirations leurs
sept chiots nakamoto déjà laissé
sous-entendre que les banques centrales
font exprès pour créer l'inflation dans
le but de voler de l'argent de citoyens
ceux des conspirations qui existe depuis
les années 30 depuis la création de la
banque
c'est difficile de départager le les
conspirations du projet de béthune parce
que ça fait partie des fondations
l'idéologie derrière on voit toute forme
de poids politique comme étant
illégitime et en créant bitcoin ce que
satoshi nakamoto le faire c'est un
système financier parallèle où on n'a
pas besoin de faire confiance non
seulement aux autorités mais à personne
d'autre qui participent dans le système
j'en ai parlé avec l'économiste francis
coppola s'intéresse beaucoup au système
d'écriture mené bon elle elle s'inquiète
beaucoup de risques financiers à ceux ci
occupent de monnaie mais elle voit aussi
un risque social à à ce que l'idéologie
derrière la roumanie se propage dans les
sociétés
christine citti strath goodship france
team bike c'est ce qu'annoncé dans cette
usine c'est intéressant de comprendre
l'histoire et l'évolution des crypto
monnaie cet écosystème partager avec la
pensée conspirationnistes mais vous
comprendre comment ça fonctionne bien et
je sais que c'est tout un défi les
grandes bases de la crypte romane ainsi
quoi on va devoir me pardonner quelques
simplifications firmes ayant des
problèmes avec cet écosystème menacé que
c'est extrêmement s'est basé sur la
technologie c'est complexe ça devient
difficile à comprendre des fois donc on
voyais à lille de la manière la plus de
balles possibles allons-y nous disposons
d'un système de finance et rationnelle
et lexie je vais t'envoyer 100 dollars
donc ma banque regardant mon condo bon
voici j'ai vraiment les fonds elle
contacta bang voici ton compte existe
des poses de 100 $ dans ton compte si
jamais il ya un problème par exemple
quelques envolées mon mot de passe puis
finalement gilles pas effectué cette
transaction englobe un la banque je peux
l'appeler elle peut annuler le
transparaissent jamais eu une fraude
mais dépôts sont assurés
l'idée derrière la crypte romane et
c'est qui on veut absolument pas faire
confiance à qui que ce soit des
institutions ou les autres participants
du système donc il ya un problème parce
qu'il n'ya pas de turfistes central qui
peut voir si j'ai vraiment les fonds que
je veux envoyer le coma ce qu'on règle
ce problème de la vision du bitcoin ses
deux descentes réaliser cette validation
donc imagine tout le monde qui
participent dans le système d'écriture
monnaie au comme un immense fichier
excel avec la liste de toutes les
transactions avec la liste de tous les
comptes et tout le monde peut les voir
occupe jeff vraiment sans douleur dans
son compte il a le droit d'envoyer 100
dollars alexis le problème avec ça c'est
que bond important qui pourrait rajouter
des transactions qui sont pas valides
donc je pourrais être envoyé 100 dollars
et en même temps envoyé 100 dollars à
quelqu'un d'autre et leurs
comptes pour résoudre ce problème là le
bitcoin
proposer une innovation quand même assez
intéressante c'est imaginer que tout le
monde dans le système veulent faire des
transactions maître d'échecs dans un
grande pile et là il ya des gens qu'on
appelle des mineurs de médecins qui
viennent y prendre des chèques dans la
pile les broches ensemble pour les
valider et les ajoute à la liste de
transaction c'est ce qu'on appelle un
bloc chain de bloc c'est un bloc comment
est ce qu'on décide qui a le droit
d'acheter un nouveau bloc à la chaîne
éliminant feront une immense compétition
partout dans le monde participe à une
loterie pour savoir qui a le droit
d'ajouter le prochain bloc sur la chaîne
the block et cette loterie le comment on
y participent c'est qu'on ya ce prix du
travail informatique assez de résoudre
des énigmes cryptographique donc on
essaie de deviner un chiffre magique
partout
des gens qui ont des banques et
d'ordinateurs qui essaient de résoudre
cette énigme l'heure il ya des milliards
et des milliards et des milliards de
tentatives par seconde partout dans le
monde la personne qui réussit à
redevenir le bon chiffre obtient le
droit de rajouter le bloc sur la chaîne
de blocs et ça devient voix officielles
comme toutes les transactions dans ce
bloc ne devienne officiel que en guise
de récompense les personnes qui ont
réussi à mettre le bloc reçoit une
récompense de bitcoin c'est comme ça
qu'on compense les gens c'est de là que
ça devient un impact environnemental
l'écriture n'est pas ce que tu as dit
énormément de travail informatique qui
prend d'électricité et serveurs des
serveurs informatiques c'est donc sa vie
ni les fermes on entend souvent parler
des films équipe toulonnaise
désorientant qui roule 24h sur 24h est
devenu le chiffre magique dans l'espoir
d'avoir la bonne réponse à l'énigme est
d'obtenir la récompense et jeff revenons
à ton exemple initiale dans le système
bancaire conventionnel tu veux me verser
à moi dans mon compte 100 dollars d'un
système des crypto monnaie comment on
fait pour annuler une transaction s'est
passé donc pour plein de raisons pour
pouvoir préserver l'intégrité du système
le système doit empêcher toute personne
d'aller modifier ce qui vient avant donc
c'est on ne peut pas changer une
transaction qui a déjà eu lieu pour
presser il ya aucune façon il n'y a pas
de service à la clientèle dans la crypte
où tu peux pas appeler une autorité
centrale pour te plaindre pour dire
écoutez il ya eu une fraude jeu mon
argent c'est impossible c'est conçu
comme ça pour ne pas nécessiter aucune
intervention
aucune autorité quelconque l'espeme est
conçu pour évaluer aux autorités il faut
pas se surprendre que c'est utilisé pour
mener toutes sortes d'activités
illégales ou du moins des activités qui
sont hautement réglementées dans le
système financier actuel j'en ai parlé
avec francis coppola qui donne des
conseils aux gens qui veulent qui
voudraient
se marier
ni
risquer un tacle aussi
comme bien des phénomènes en vogue
l'univers des crypto menez est construit
sur une série de mythes ses mythes sont
tenaces et constitue dans l'esprit de
ceux qui croient les raisons pour
lesquelles les crypto monnaie serait la
voie de l'avenir en matière de finances
et deux transactions monétaires mais à
bien des égards ces croyances relève
davantage du mirage comme nous allons le
démontrer
des boulots ou des construisons des
mettent ensemble jeff numéro un la cre
et aux monnaies c'est une monnaie oui ou
non je pense que même les les plus
fervents partisans
la fonction c'est à peu près impossible
d'acheter des choses dans la vraie vie
avec bitcoin comme payer son loyer
acheter de l'essence
faire le prix est beaucoup trop volatile
de l'est compagnie qui a accepté la
crypte romane est comme fond de paiement
et quelques années mais il y en a de
moins en moins le prix varie tellement
par exemple aubin s'est subitement de
40% en fin d'année l'année dernière puis
aussi pour eux le système bitcoin au
complet peut effectuer en trois sets
transactions par seconde partout dans le
monde donc ça peu près impossible que
toute la planète se mettent à utiliser
bitcoin comme monnaie d'échangé des
nouveaux systèmes qui sont en
développement qui ont été proposées pour
augmenter la vitesse il ya d'autres
chanteurs mais le principal destinataire
fonctionne pas vraiment comme une
monnaie plus comme un vieux spéculatifs
en investissement autre mythe est-ce que
c'est véritablement décentralisées comme
système sur papier où il à n'importe qui
peut participer au système de mini bibis
quand même le travail informatique et ça
nécessite de nos jours c'est que c'est
absolument immense
c'est à peu près impossible pour une
personne de juste faire opérer un
système d'évaluation sur son ordinateur
personnel d'ailleurs d immense
conglomérat de ménage de béton qui
existait une poignée de ses conglomérats
de contrôle la plupart des activités de
minage des prime donc programme
décentralisée quand on sait que ce sont
une poignée d'acteurs qui dans le fond
font fonctionner le stand bacon ou si le
système de bitcoin sûr partie on peut
l'utiliser nous même effectué nous mêmes
des transactions en injectant dans le
bloc uni note une infime minorité des
gens cela comme un tir d'essai la
plupart utilisent des services des
changes populaires comme bénin script au
point comme prix à kim dong
concentration des services de bigpoint
aussi et ses services l'offre si vous
voulez effectuer par exemple des
transactions de thomas né avec de
l'argent liquide avec de l'argent du
steinbach à faut donner transformation
personnelle donc c'est plus vraiment
décentralisée parce qu'on doit faire
confiance à l'application qui nous
permet de transit géant en coupe du
monde et puisque tu pars de confiance la
confiance des gens dans l'univers des
crypto monnaie est souvent basée sur la
notion d'anonymat c'est encore est ce
que c'est vrai encore une fois sur
papier oui donc pour créer un
portefeuille bien on a juste besoin de
clé cryptographique privé une clé
publique on n'a pas besoin de rentrer
son nom des informations personnelles
pour se créer un portefeuille donc miss
et ses anonymes ces pseudonymes l'
affaire c'est que comme on disait tantôt
il ya une immense transparence dans le
système
d'écriture menés dans le sens qu'on peut
aller voir toutes les transactions qui
ont eu lieu depuis le début donc si on
connaît ton numéro d'adressent de ton
portefeuille toute aumône et on peut
aller voir des transactions qui ont eu
lieu et on peut aller voir à qui tu
donnes l'argent ça permet aux autorités
de retracer des gens donc c'est pas tout
à fait en année mais surtout si on
connecte son portefeuille à un système
des changes où on demande des
informations personnelles la ce a permis
aux autorités justement d'aller bloquer
votre compte sur un échange donc sur
patty oui c'est un anonyme dans les
filles passant pour ça